this is what happened to Andrew Tate
right he got canceled as being as people
making assumptions about his character
when they don't [ __ ] know his
character right because like like you
somebody can say any like does that do I
agree with everything that he said about
like like women and [ __ ] no am I
personally offended by anything he said
no because I don't know him right but
like I also see that he's a smart man
he's extremely intelligent he has a he
is he's a Matt he has a six like
massively successful business online
business
and then you start thing seeing like oh
well how did he do that well one of the
reasons how he did that is by being
polarizing you have to be you being
polarizing is an asset in order to stand
out on the internet and social media if
if 50 of people love you and fifty
percent of people hate you that's a
pretty good ratio that's a pretty good
ratio because you then because that
polarization is getting attention that
attention is getting some people are
going to hate you cool [ __ ] off the
people that are gonna love you are gonna
[ __ ] love you and they're your tribe
right and that's who you want so you're
you're you're you're you're broadcasting
yourself to more people to to [ __ ]
love you right and so it's it's like
like why does that mean if he has a
controversial opinion from some from
some outtakes that are people are
posting on like of his content about
this or that why does that why why does
that give the powers that be the right
to to cancel him to remove him
completely to delete him what gives them
the right to do that
so that we don't have free speech that's
what it's saying is saying we don't have
free speech it's saying if you get if if
you become so successful
if you be if you reach this level of
success and you're still voicing your
[ __ ] opinions
freely then you're gone you're gone
because if he wasn't successful no one
would even give a [ __ ] there's people
every like regular people every day that
post crazy wild [ __ ] on Instagram and no
one gives a [ __ ] because they're no
buddies yeah but if you reach this level
of success and you're making this much
money and and you're making this money
from an online business meaning on over
the Internet well if it's successful now
you're not allowed to voice an opinion
now if your voice and opinion and you're
making your money from the internet Boop
you're off the internet
you know that's [ __ ] wrong that's
wrong yeah that's way more wrong than
any like controversial opinion Andrew
Tate said about anything about like you
know women obviously like you know like
calling them [ __ ] or whatever okay
like okay I can see how people are like
that's not cool but I can also see
people like that's just how he [ __ ]
talks okay that's how he talks that's
how he talks people can talk however the
[ __ ] they want and I'm not gonna and I'm
gonna be able to sit there and go okay
well this is how this person is is
expressing himself this is how they talk
if if it's not the way I would talk who
am I to go you have to talk the way I
talk you know what I'm saying or you
don't have the right to speak if you're
not going to use the terminology that
that I that that I agree with right that
this is there where's this is like a
this is a creating a [ __ ] a world
where they're only one voice is allowed
to speak
instead of all voices are allowed to
speak and have a [ __ ] conversation
all right I hear you loud and clearly
thing we sat down with Tate for I know I
watched five six hours like I think it's
absolutely disgusting that they uh a lot
of these digital uh social governments
have have canceled him they do have
terms of services that's a whole
conversation where I think I got really
disgusting or the credit card processors
and Ubers and PayPal and Airbnb and
exactly what the [ __ ] is that what is
that that's insane to me so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign
[Music]